Beyonce and Blue Ivy shut it down during
the Hollywood premiere of The Lion King
in fierce matching ensembles Queen B had
a mother-daughter date night adobe
Theatre at the premiere of her new film
Simba you have to take your place as
king
we need you the actress who voices Nala
in the Disney live-action film wowed in
a crystal chandelier embroidered
alexander mcqueen tuxedo dress with a
see-through crystal embellished skirts
she also rocked crystal jewelry pin
heeled sandals and carried a bedazzled
fox plush with a jeweled handled topping
off the glam with long braids and a
sultry smoky eye Bea's seven-year-old
mini-me matched her mama in a black
dress with silver crystal embellishment
during the red carpet
et caught up with B's bestie and former
Destiny's Child member Michelle Williams
who praised her for being a part of this
iconic story we all lost our minds and
we heard Beyonce's voice as Nala when
you first heard that
what was your react just excitement and
how now is the time you know different
voices different experiences and what
she's gonna bring to it and because of
her too little girl you know what she's
passing on for her family I think is
really awesome he must take your place
in the circle of life Beyonce also
dropped an epic anthem spirit on Tuesday
night as part of the movie's soundtrack
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but the musical numbers don't stop there
as the Lion King the gift an album
produced and curated by Queen B
featuring a global artists releases with
the film on July 19
[Music]
[Music]